[Music]
all right the race for the White House
for 20.24 continues so at the grand old
age of 80 Joe Biden your president he is
by far the most failed president least
that I've seen in my lifetime probably
in the history of the U.S and yet now he
wants a second term in office
unfortunately for Joe well gravity seems
to have other ideas now yesterday the
entire country walked in shock another
scary looking fall tumbling to the
ground with a loud thump after having to
be helped to his feet by multiple
onlookers well then Biden appeared dazed
he appeared confused when he took a seat
his breathing was visibly labored didn't
look particularly well and no doubt it
was a pretty scary moment for the
president but it wasn't just the fall
that's deeply concerning earlier in the
day Biden needed a lot of help special
help to find the stage and the podium
and during the speech Joe had some well
let's call them unusual moments take a
look it wasn't all push-ups and cramming
for Prague week
though uh to set the Guinness Book of
Records World Records most simultaneous
push-ups there had to be an enormous
amount of push-ups
what about doing well barrel rolls
rolls I asked if I could do that today
just people and the Secret Service said
no we'll have to shoot it down
by the way I met with uh who those guys
that fly over shortly you heard them
haven't
three of them are women and your class
is one of the first most diverse classes
in the history of this Academy or any
Academy to graduate that's why we're
strong that's why we're who we are
that's why we'll never give up that's
why
who are those guys that are about to do
the flyover thing anyway so after those
very bizarre remarks Biden returned home
to the White House and what happens well
he hit his head on Marine one he then
told the Press Corps that a rogue
sandbag was responsible for him tripping
and falling take a look
[Music]
well unfortunately it appears that Biden
has bigger problems than being
sandbagged but the media mob they don't
seem to care fake news CNN msdnc they
barely mentioned Biden's fall like it
never happened in contrast four years
ago here's how they covered Donald Trump
remember it was raining he had a ramp it
didn't have a railing of any kind and it
was a very wet outdoor speech he gave at
West Point and so in dress shoes he
walked slowly never fell he very wisely
walked slowly take a look
president Trump is now the oldest
president to hold office during a first
term as he celebrated his 74th birthday
yesterday however this Milestone is
bringing up new questions about his
health particularly over the moment um
with this weekend where he cautiously
descended a ramp during the commencement
speech at West Point Academy tonight new
questions about President Trump's Health
after this walk down a ramp at West
Point's Graduation Ceremony this weekend
one doesn't need to be a physician to
note that the president hasn't looked
well recently and he didn't look well on
Saturday having momentary stumbles
momentary lapses and you know it looks
restraining for a word or whatever it
might be president Trump is not known
for being athletic
so maybe he just has a hard time going
down a gently sloping ramp but
um do you see something possibly
neurological that could be throwing off
his balance
it just it's so hard to say
it's amazing the media mom had nothing
to say about Joe tripping and falling
yet again yesterday hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else